my name is sheikha I'm the senior
entertainment manager on board the
beautiful disneywet I just love being
around the different kinds of people
that we have on board and
and the uniqueness of living at sea
[Music]
favorite part of what I do here is the
people it's definitely a very diverse
place to work
[Music]
so we're all from all over and we're all
here to deliver the same product which
is really nice to come together as a
team
[Music]
so my typical day on board I wake up
nice and early I always like to start
the day with a cup of tea we have a
variety of foods available for our
different nationalities on board in the
crew mess it's different every day
I would also at some point throughout
the day head to the gym I do like to
work out and we do have a great facility
on board for the crew
[Music]
foreign
the beautiful Castaway Key which is a
beautiful island that we have I like to
get off and head to the beach
[Music]
sometimes we like to have an active
Beach day where you're using the paddle
boards and The Kayaks which is super fun
and other days you just kind of like to
sit on that lounger and not move and
just take in that vitamin D
so my typical day on board we have
rehearsals throughout the day so if
there's a rehearsal I would check in
with the teams doing a staging rehearsal
and blocking rehearsal to make sure
they're all in the right place on stage
with Disney Cruise Line and Disney
itself we'd like to tell a story every
show belongs to a certain venue because
of a story because of a reason
for Marvel to snuggly Declan to story
times a lot of variety around the ship
for all to enjoy
a pirate show on board is a beautiful
fun show we have live music that plays
throughout the entire show and they also
play during the fireworks moment too
I'll be in the booth and I call the
queues for the show one minute
[Music]
I guess I've never sailed on a ship
before some have sailed 30 times we want
each one of them to feel welcome we have
a wonderful crew to help create the
atmosphere of Enchantment and deliver to
our guests
oh
[Music]